LuAnn de Lesseps reunites with her Real
Housewives of New York City squad after
leaving an alcohol treatment center and
et has the pic the 52 year old reality
star recently left the alcohol treatment
center she checked herself into after
she was arrested in Palm Beach Florida
on Christmas Eve on charges of
disorderly intoxication resisting arrest
and battery on a law enforcement officer
she pleaded not guilty on Monday night
Ramona Singer shared this pic on
Instagram of her and de Lesseps seated
at a table with their Bravo cast mates
including Sonja Morgan Bethenny Frankel
Tinsley Mortimer Dorinda medley and
Carole R as well she captioned the shot
quote the gang's all here
but later deleted it meanwhile Morgan
and Reds will posted pics of the cast
posing for fake mug shots noticeably
missing from the shoot de Lesseps prior
to entering a treatment facility the
housewives star issued several apologies
quote I am committed to a transformative
and hopeful 2018 and on Tuesday she
tweeted quote it's good to be home I'm
doing great
you